i will i am going to play a video video
for you from fox news
that makes it very clear fox news is
positioning itself
to hit the abort button on supporting
donald trump they're getting ready to
dump trump and support ron desantis in
2024 but they're leaving themselves an
open window
to support trump if trump is the nominee
so if if you were doubting that fox news
would rather trump not be the nominee
check out this
deliberately edited man on the street
type segment where fox news reporters
went out
and they were talking to random trump
voters and the question was do you want
trump to run again
or not and of course
they could have crafted this in any way
that they want you can just keep
interviewing people until you get the
clips that you want
they selected mostly random trump voters
who don't want trump running in 2024. it
is very clear that fox news is setting
themselves up to abort the trump train
take a look at this i don't want him to
i like uh like what he stands for i like
what he does but uh
he upset too many people and he upset
him really bad so i don't think he's
good for the party he needs to get back
in
he already had gained that respect from
all the world leaders and finish what he
you know started by the way that's the
random trump supporter in there he
gained respect from world leaders world
leaders were laughing at him
literally both behind his back and
sometimes to his face behind his back at
a number of different different summits
to his face at that wacky u n speech
where the room just started laughing at
trump
respect
it's too bad that he did what he
did do and was fought the whole way
along on
star near everything that he did but
that's what happened so i'd
like to see him not run if he did i
would vote for him but i would not
recommend he runs i i voted for trump
both times and i i love him i think he
was a good candidate but i think his
time has passed i couldn't care less
about president trump uh personally um
i i prefer somebody different but if he
is the nominee i'll probably vote for
him you know what i voted for him for my
my very first time i voted for him i
don't think he'll be best for our
country for him to
run for reelection you know i'm thankful
for everything that he's done
but i think that our republican party
needs to be united at this point he's a
little too polarizing and i think that
there are candidates out there
republican candidates obviously
that um
maybe be able to pull in people that he
would lose to be able to change this i
would like to see you know governor
desantis or someone like that some some
new blood in in the race desantis
run for president and if he wants to
then he can pick up donald as the vice
president we're from florida um
desantis is we're big fans of desantis
on this one he seems to be much more
common sense
and able to communicate better to both
sides
to get those people back then
so remember they could have picked
anybody they could interview that
they're only including a few people in
this they could have interviewed 50 or
60 or 70 people and gotten whatever they
wanted everybody's saying trump should
run or not everybody's saying to santa
they have chosen these people to create
this story the switch he's done a good
job and everything he's tried to do
despite all you know it's not all just
what he says it doesn't just happen like
that
i believe he's done a good job with a
lot of things and that's just my
personal beliefs i really like desantis
all right so you get it
fox is in total control of this story
they could make it say anything they
could turn it into a campaign ad for
trump if they wanted it they are looking
towards the future
they seem to think the future is not
trump and the long-term
viability of fox news as a business
enterprise depends on it being sort of
like the state media arm
of some republican authoritarian regime
and so this is self-interest at work i
want people to understand that it's not
about they like trump's foreign policy
or they don't like it or whatever uh the
idea here is they want
to get someone other than trump in
if trump ends up winning the nomination
of course they will still back him but
right now they're saying we think we
will be better off with the old version
of fox where we just all get behind a
more
popular authoritarian right-wing regime
rather than someone who's as polarizing
and so they've crafted this narrative
everybody seems to want desantis
we will see
how the primary shakes out if and when
people announced neither trump nor
desantis have yet announced but this is
probably part of why trump would rather
make the announcement sooner than later
that he's running and um it will be to
his advantage in order to push people to
have to take more of a risk to not
support him right now with no one
declared it's easier for fox to run
these pieces hey look it just sort of
seems like the public wants someone else
and that someone else happens to be ron
desantis if trump announces
it puts them in a much more difficult
position to keep running anti-trump
pro-desantis pieces so that's to trump's
interest then to announce sooner every
indication is that he's going to do that